مرحبًا ، أنا دانا سانتيس
، مدرب حركة التنفس والعقل والجسم في الرياضات الاحترافية ،
أود مشاركة خمسة تمارين للمساعدة في
تخفيف تأثير الجلوس لفترات طويلة
عندما نجلس كثيرًا ، فقد يؤدي ذلك
إلى حدوث آلام مزمنة في الرقبة والظهر والكتف
بالإضافة إلى مشاكل الموقف  يمكن أن يظهر هذا الألم
كمستوى من التوتر الذي يمكن أن
يؤثر علينا عقليًا ، كما أن هذه
التمارين لن تساعدك فقط على التحرك
بشكل أفضل ولكن أيضًا تساعدك على الشعور بالتحسن
ويمكنك القيام بهذه التمارين في
أي مكان تقريبًا كما لو كنت في مكتبي اليوم ، لذا
فلنبدأ
هذه التدريبات الثلاثة الأولى التي يجب عليك
القيام بها طوال يومك لتفريق
النوبات المطولة من الجلوس ،
قد تتعرف عليها إذا كنت تمارس
اليوجا لأنها تستند إلى محارب معدل ،
أسميه محاربًا مدعومًا
بإطلاق ثني
الورك الآن  هذه العضلات من
هنا والتي يتم ضغطها وشدها
طوال اليوم أثناء جلوسنا ، لذلك
هذا ما سنركز عليه
في هذا التمرين ، فلنبدأ بهذا الوضع
الأيسر  g مرة أخرى في نوع من
وقفة المحارب القصيرة وستكون ركبتك الأمامية
فوق كاحلك مباشرة الآن
عندما تخطو هذه الساق للخلف ، قد
تبدأ بالفعل في الشعور بتمدد في
ثني الورك وهذا رائع ولكننا
سنزيده بإضافة هذا الذراع  إذن ، هذا ما
نفعله نأخذ ذراعك الأيسر ونصله لأعلى ،
وستشعر بهذه الضلوع
وتدخل وتضيق مائلك على هذا الجانب
قليلاً للمساعدة في دعمك ،
وهذا أمر ممتاز ، سنحتفظ بهذا
لثلاثة أنفاس
الآن بينما تستمر في التنفس
، شهيقًا كبيرًا وزفيرًا لطيفًا للغاية ، فقط
تأكد من أنك لا تغير وضعك ،
لذلك لا أريدك أن
تقوس ظهرك وأنت تستنشق هذه
الضلوع ، ستشعر بأن غلوتك تدور ،
فلنأخذ  نفس آخر
طويل وعميق بطيء
ثم آخر
رائع ثم نكرره على
الجانب الآخر
[موسيقى]
هذا التمرين التالي عبارة عن
لف طاحونة مدعومة وهو مصمم للمساعدة في
التخلص من كل هذا التوتر الذي
نشعر به من
الجلوس أيضًا  طويل في متراجع
الوضع بحيث يخفف التوتر
في الجزء العلوي من الجسم ، ستجلس وركيك للخلف
، وتضع ساعدك على المكتب ، ومن ثم
من المهم جدًا
أن تحافظ على أسفل
ظهرك مغلقًا عندما تجلس إلى الوراء.  استدر
من أسفل الظهر ، فقط منتصف الظهر
يصل إلى ذراعك الأيسر للأمام ، استدر أولاً
من كتفك
، ثم عندما تصل إلى أعلى
الآن نبدأ في التحرك من منتصف الظهر ،
لكن لاحظ أن ظهري السفلي يظل مستقرًا هنا ،
سنحمل هذا  لثلاثة أنفاس
وتريد أن تحاول التنفس طويلًا وعميقًا
، خذ شهيقًا كبيرًا وزفيرًا لطيفًا
أثناء التنفس ، حاول معرفة ما إذا كان
بإمكانك الدوران ربما
مرة أخرى قليلاً ليس من أسفل ظهرك فقط من
منتصف الظهر لذلك عندما  ربما
يتوسع الشهيق قليلاً ، وبينما تقوم
بالزفير ، قم بتدوير تلك الضلوع اليمنى
لترى ما إذا كان يمكنك الحصول على المزيد منها
مرة أخيرة
، ثم عند الزفير ، نعيده
لأسفل
ثم نخرج ونكرره على
الجانب الآخر
[موسيقى]
هذا exer  سيساعدك cise على التخلص
من كل هذا التوتر في مقدمة
كتفيك وصدرك الذي يحدث
من الجلوس في مكاتبنا أمام
أجهزة الكمبيوتر الخاصة بنا والنظر إلى هواتفنا طوال اليوم ،
ستحتاج فقط إلى إطار باب حتى
تتمكن من وضع ذراعك  مع
مستوى كوعك مع كتفك على
إطار الباب ، ثم يبقى هذا على هذا النحو
بينما نحرك جسمنا
في الامتداد ، لذا فأنا أقوم فقط بإدارة
جسدي حتى أبدأ في الشعور بالتمدد
الذي قد لا تذهب بعيدًا مثلي هذا  قم به
بشكل منتظم لأنه أحد
تلك التمارين التي يجب عليك القيام
بها مرتين في اليوم لتفريق
نوبات الجلوس
هذه ، لذا احتفظ بهذا لمدة ثلاثة أنفاس
فقط تأكد من أنك لا تعاني من أي ألم ،
يجب ألا تكون هذه التمارين مؤلمة
خذ نفسًا آخر ،
يجب أن تشعر بالإفراج ، فهذا لا
يعني أنه من السهل القيام به ، ولكن
يجب أن تشعر أن هذا الإصدار يأخذ
نفسًا أخيرًا
ممتازًا وبالطبع لدينا
جانبان تريد القيام به على
الجانب الآخر أيضًا
[موسيقى  ]
هذين التمرينين التاليين  صُممت
لتكون تصحيحية لوضعية جسمك
وتساعدك على الحفاظ على وضع أفضل ، لذا من
الناحية المثالية ، سترغب في القيام بذلك مرة واحدة
يوميًا ،
وهذا ما يسمى بملائكة الحائط الآن ، يبدو الأمر
سهلاً ولكن عندما تحاول ذلك
ستدرك أنه في الواقع هادئ
صعب ، لذا ستبذل
قصارى جهدك لشغل المنصب الآن ، فأنا على بعد حوالي
ست إلى ثماني بوصات من
الحائط بكعبتي ، ثم أجلس نوعًا ما
في الحائط مع
ثني ركبتي طفيفًا
يجب أن تكون ذراعي لأعلى ومرفقي
على مستوى كتفي
، ثم سأستنشق عندما أبدأ في
تحريك ذراعي لأعلى
ثم الزفير بينما
أعود إلى وضع البداية الأصلي ،
لذلك يكون هذا تكرارًا واحدًا لذلك مع كل
نفس أنت '  سأقوم بالتكرار لما
مجموعه خمسة الآن ما أريده على الرغم من أنه
لا يرتفع لدرجة أنك تفقد نقطة الاتصال ،
لذلك عندما أستنشق وأعود ،
لا أريد ذراعي أن تبتعد عن
الحائط أريد  لإبقائهم على
الحائط بحيث يكون المرفقان
ظهري ضد  الجدار يستنشق مرة أخرى
ثم الزفير لأسفل لن يكون مثاليًا
ولكن ابذل قصارى جهدك يبقى رأسي
على الحائط وكذلك يستنشق
الزفير لأسفل الآن تريد حقًا
التركيز على أنفاسك أنا
أتحدث إليك كما أفعل  أفعل هذا حتى لا
أركز على أنفاسي بقدر
الزفير القوي الذي ينزل به
القفص الصدري لأسفل في نفس
الوقت ، لذلك دعونا نقوم بتمرين آخر
ثم إلى أسفل
هذا التمرين الأخير أسميه جسر التنفس
ويمكن القول إنه
أهم تمرين ليس فقط في
السلسلة ولكن في جميع البرامج التي أقوم
بإنشائها للناس ، لذا أود أن
تقوم بهذا التمرين كل يوم إن أمكن
ذلك لن يساعدك فقط في
وضعيتك ولكن في تنفسك وحركتك بشكل عام
للقيام بذلك  ستحصل في هذا التمرين على
وضع
مثلي ويمكنك استخدام كتلة يوغا إسفنجية
بين ركبتيك أو إذا لم يكن لديك
واحدة فقط ارفع منشفة ، فأنا أحب
شيئًا ما هناك لتثبيت
ركبتيك وفخذيك.  ضع يديك على
ضلوعك  لأننا نولي
اهتمامًا حقيقيًا لتوجيه ومراقبة
حركة ضلوعنا هنا ، لذا فإن اليدين على ضلوعك السفلية
ثم الزفير دافعًا تلك
الضلوع نحو بعضها البعض نحو
الأرض وإلى أسفل نحو خصرك ، لذا
تعامل مع هذا مثل زفير تمرين أساسي
يشعر بك  تشغيل الأساسية الآن لا تتنفس ،
فقط أمسك بهذا وأريدك أن
ترفع وركيك إلى أعلى مع إمالة حوضك لأسفل
حتى تشعر بأن عضلات المؤخرة تعمل الآن ، امسك
هذا الموضع واستنشق ولاحظ
أننا نتنفس من
خلال أنفنا وتخرج من خلاله  أنفنا
المهم هنا أن الضلوع تخرج
الزفير وستتحرك الضلوع
للخلف والأسفل مرة أخرى
ثم تستنشق
تشعر أن ضلوعك تتحرك للخارج ثم الزفير
استمر في الحفاظ على هذا الوضع
مرة أخرى
ثم الشهيق ثم الزفير الآن كما تفعل ذلك
أنت  قد تلاحظ أن ذقنك تبدأ
في الظهور ، استخدم هذا الزفير لجذب
ذقنك مرة أخرى حيث تتحرك تلك الأضلاع
للخلف وللأسفل ثم تستنشق مرة أخرى
ثم الزفير يجب أن يرتاح
وجهك على تلك الزفير.  أو الانخراط على
الرغم من أن الألوية تظل منشغلة بالشهيق في المرة الأخيرة
ثم الزفير وستقوم بإحضار
الوركين للأسفل
ومن ثم يمكنك تدحرج نفسك
، وكما قلت ، أوصي بممارسة هذا
التمرين مرة واحدة على الأقل كل يوم
[موسيقى]